what is up guys my name is the general
welcome to episode 15 of 30 game
programming in Java okay it's been a
long time it's been like what two three
weeks I'm sorry if you followed my
channel than you knew that I had exams
and yeah and then I'm actually over
today's actually Thursday I've got one
last exam tomorrow but you know I've had
the day off today so I decided why not
uh why don't record this this episode
and have it ready for Sunday so here we
are and you guys probably gonna kill me
for not releasing on Thursday but I'm
sorry
sunday is da day okay let's get started
okay so first of all this is where we
left off as you saw and actually I
probably probably say what what exactly
we're going to be doing today textures
is where we are going to be doing today
okay now it was kind of a mixed bag okay
this time there was no clear winner but
I'm pretty sure textures won in the end
so this is the little thing lot of
responses are 48 responses for this one
because of course people had three weeks
to respond um and a lot of you guys
basically said textures like you can see
here that a lot of them say textures I'm
not gonna go very far because I don't
have that much time but uh textures so
there we go
mouse movement ah we're gonna have to
delay that okay I would prefer to
actually finished off the mouse movement
stuff but you know you guys you guys
obviously uh wanted textures so that's
what we're doing okay well it's not what
I meant to do okay let's get started um
one thing I want to do though and I saw
this in the comments and I thought you
know why didn't I do this earlier and
that is the FPS counter okay rather than
printing off the FPS counter here and
obviously you can say that it's sort of
suffering here because we're not
actually armed we can't really see the
FPS counter because it says still and
that's sort of in the way so what I want
to do is basically just print the FPS
counter over here in the corner and you
can't see it because the mouse goes away
let me just fix that real quick just
comment out the cursor thing
I'll restart it so we'll have the mouse
thing right over here did sorry not the
mouse thing the render distance what am
I talking about the FPS I haven't done
tutorials in a while so yeah you're just
going to have to bear with me if this
one will have the FPS counter sort of
displayed over here nice big text so
that we can actually see the FPS rather
than you don't have to deal with this
stuff in the console and also this is
great if you want to test on different
computers that's what I always do if I'm
working on a big project obviously not
this but if I was working on a big
project and when I do work on big
projects what I do is actually export
the actual jar file bring it onto a
different computer and I have the FPS
displayed here or wherever basically on
the screen so that I can see how it
performs on another computer and so
that's really important so I want to
talk about that today as well as
textures so let's get started this is
going to be like a like little bonus
feature for you guys because I know that
I didn't actually do um I didn't
actually get to do an episode for a
while so this is like a little little
bonus feature for this episode so let's
get started ok um let me see here so the
way we're going to basically print our
fps is we let's have a look at this
let's approach this from a from a
practical point of view we have this
system we have this line of code here
that is printing out our fps right and
what we want to do is instead of print
it in the console which is right over
here we right we actually want to print
it inside the jframe so how we going to
do that let me just rename the mouse so
that we lose the mouse yep cool so how
do we actually make it display in the
actual frame let's go up here to our
render method so our render method or
function you can also call them
functions but method is the correct term
there might there may be called
functions in other programming languages
I didn't mention that earlier so if
you're coming from like I don't know
another programming language which calls
like groups of code functions I guess
that this is a method in Java but that's
what you call it in Java but it can also
be known as a function this is this is
sort of like the method that rent is our
actual stuff and we we see here the word
the graphics so what the graphics API
with the graphics um API I guess has
what the graphics library has is a
drawstring thing so if we go down here
and we just type G after right beneath G
draw image which we type G draw string
then we can see it comes up here and
let's just like the bottom one right
here and hit enter okay so now we've got
our basic a draw string method calling
from the graphics library so basically
it's asking us for three things and as
well if you're like if you're sort of
just going around java and exploring all
the different api's and man um libraries
and saladna classes then a thing that
helps you is these three things it needs
three or two column three values
basically it needs a string and two
integers it acts and in the Y I'm sure
you can guess what int X and int Y is so
if my voice is a bit mmm I've just I
don't know why what a really sore throat
today so I'm sorry if my voice is not as
as sexy as normal but yeah nothing I can
do about that I'm unfortunately yeah so
it's wanting a string and it's wanting
two integers so it's called this one X
for you so you can probably guess that's
the x position on screen why is the Y
position on the screen and the string is
probably what you actually want to draw
the draw string so the actual string of
text you want to draw on the screen okay
so cool let's just end this x and y
position I don't know let's just put
this to like 50 and 50 20 maybe and now
we've got so yeah we've sort of filled
out we've told the draw string method
where exactly we want the the text to
appear in terms of the coordinates of it
but we haven't told it what to print yet
so let's just print say test and if we
fire this up then we should get tests
and as you can see we do have tests the
problem is and I'll just try and yeah
you can see it right there it sort of in
the top left corner
problem here is that first of all it's
tiny and second of all it's black which
isn't racist it's just it's bad at this
point basically okay and the other
problem is Lee is that we actually
wanted to dynamically change the
drawstring and the drawstring is
supposed to be this so first of all
let's go ahead and make this pretty and
we can do that pretty easily let's just
set the font first so G dot set font and
we'll set that to a new font and we'll
have to import foreign to actually in
let's just do that right now and we'll
set it to verdana because that's my
favorite font it's a really good web
font I just use it for web development
so actually I didn't explain this letter
set this to zero for now and fifty okay
so right here if you actually mouse over
then you'll see that it wants two
integers and a string so basically what
this what this first parameter that's
the word parameter what this first
parameter is is the string so it's
wanting the name of the actual font you
want to use secondly it's wanting an
integer and that is the style so by
style what it means and I can see we're
already at eight minutes and we're still
doing this thing so this is gonna be a
long tutorial guys get ready anyway so
basically what's basically what style
means is style is bold italics and bold
and italics at the same time so it's
only it's only gives you four choices
basically zero is normal one is one is
bold two is italics and three is bold
and italics and I'll show you guys that
in a second and fifty is the actual size
of the font fifty is a nice size so now
that we now if we boot this up I'll save
it we can see the test is a lot bigger
but the color is still kind of bad and
that's that's easily solved we just need
to make another thing called G dot set
color and we'll set this to color dot
just that's the cyan blue is going to be
a bit darker and so science should be
fine so yeah there we go
um I'm going to set it to yellow
actually
all fraps style yellow and yeah that
looks good so as you can see we've got
nice text printed now and basically the
only prog a actually hang on first of
all I just want to quickly demonstrate
the different styles so we have normal
which is let me just move this back back
this up a bit
okay that's cool okay stop moving
dude okay there we go so we have um we
have our zero which is there we have one
which is bold as you can see changed
to which is italics and three is bold
and italics okay so play around with
that I kind of like italics actually for
this one but you can probably just leave
it on sorry concepts whatever you like I
just just it's just it's plainly
esthetical of course and I just it
aesthetically pleasing it lit to have it
on an italics okay so that's just my
personal preference um so yeah now we've
got this printed okay so we've pretty
much done all we need to actually do is
say okay well instead of printing test
we want to print a variable we want to
print the integer the frames integer
okay where are we yup here and the
problem is a straight away that if we
try to print frames frames then it's not
going to let us because it cannot be
resolved to a variable because that
variable is within the running thing so
what we need to do and um I'm just going
to do it this way okay
I'm just going to make a new integer
call it f and I want to call it fps
alright I'm not going to edit or
anything equal to any value and then I'm
going to go over here and just under
this I'm going to set FPS equals frames
so all I'm doing here is I'm setting the
value of FPS this integer that we've
created for the whole class and I've set
it to private so we can only access it
in this class and I basically I set it
equal to
frames every time frames updates itself
and if we go here we print FPS what you
should get if this works probably oh
yeah that's the other thing we need to
do not anything that actually ok so
there's a small problem and that is that
it can't actually print the integer and
that's alright because there's in Java
there's basically a little thing they
have that converts FPS into sorry it
converts integers into strengths and and
we could use that to convert the FPS the
frames frames variable into into a
string but I'm not going to do that I'm
actually going to do it the easier way
um let's change this back to n actually
don't worry about that I don't know I
just completely forgot that it said draw
string not draw in and all we basically
so I can work around all we have to do
is print the the integer along with a
string so FPS let's just leave a space
okay so that should work let's go ahead
and run it
yep there we go so as you can see we've
got a perfectly awesome frame per second
counter we're going to FPS counter in
the top left of our screen whose
position we can move and yeah we've got
nice FPS here maybe FPS nah just playing
around with what it looks like that
doesn't look yeah I'll just leave it as
it was ok so now we have our FPS counter
armed and you can you know just remove
the position I think that looks what
oh yeah that's fine actually there we go
50 was fine okay so that is the first
part apart the first half probably of
our tutorial of episode 15 and we've
done lies FPS counter so that we can
actually just test this stuff in the
future okay so let's move on to textures
because we all love textures okay
so the first thing I want to do with
textures is actually create the texture
so I'm gonna open paint.net and all of
my don't worry all my tool stuff is on
the other screen my other screen so if
you don't see them don't worry okay so
first thing I want to do is actually
we'll just make a simple 8x8 Tasha and
we can actually will actually get into
changing that we might make some higher
as textures some other time but I didn't
really want to do textures at this point
because it's the aesthetical stuff and
we haven't actually got the core game
mechanics down yet so that's why I'm
sort of taking it easy and I'm just
satisfying you guys because you wanted
textures and here you are here are your
textures um so let's just make a
gradient real quick and I'm just going
to drag it like that and we can get a
nice pixelated sort of image I think the
other way around maybe I want to make it
sort of light and that looks nice so
let's save this and actually that brings
me to my second point let's just open
this up okay so this is our directory
right this is in your Eclipse workspace
and this is in your project file and the
project folder and here it is so we have
all of our source code right over here
in our packages in our folders will be
created and here's all of our source
code so let's make another folder for
the resources so let's name it res so
res is short for resources okay and
let's make another folder here I'm just
going to call it textures and into this
folder I'm going to save the image so
there's also textures and I'm just going
to say this is floor PNG head okay okay
so now we have saved our wonderful
texture looks fantastic
and now we're ready to basically just
work on actually embedding it into the
floor so let's get started with that
first thing I'm going to do is come in
here graphics and create a new class you
know not new package new class I'm just
going to call it textures texture and
hit finish okay so this is basically
going to gonna have a bunch of budget
code in there and what the purpose of
this class is to just load the image
basically so let's go ahead and return a
result it's to load the image and return
the image as a useable texture so let's
go ahead and just go public static
render and in render we're just going to
make a floor object out of render and
we're going to set it to load bitmap and
we're going to load the actual file so
where do we put it we put it into our
resources folder but we put it into
textures but remember thee it's not
yeah I'm just used to the then on /in
web development but make sure you put
that forward slash in actually might
work without it I haven't tried it floor
top ng right so it's basically going to
load that bitmap and we've made these
this load bitmap thing but we haven't
actually like made it yet so let's go
ahead and make it rounder load bitmap
and basically all a bitmap is going to
do is it's going to have a string and
we're going to name that name that
string file name so in other words here
is that string so it's loading this so
we've set up like a nice file loading
system here and well this is a method
and we're going to have to try to do
this because again it could fail for
example if the actual image if this
actual file file does not exist it will
fail so we're going to use buffered
image to load it and basically we're
going to make and I'll do it out of that
and set it to image input output
I read so that's what that's what we're
going to do and it's going to read
texture and it imported it automatically
which is nice texture class get resource
and it's going to get that file name
resource right so basically what I did
here is instead of just putting the file
name here I just set it to this so that
if we want to change it it's easy to
change okay it's really simple and we'll
have to import it it imported here put
our foot not the dot buffered image
don't know why okay
also I'm going to have to actually have
it return a result so we've loaded this
image now we need to return the image so
that we can use it within our render 3d
class in order to actually apply that
texture to the floor so let's come in
here and to the floor and ceiling let's
come in here and create two two integers
and this space is going to be the width
of our image and it's basically just
going to be set to image don't get with
and again the same thing for height so
image don't get height so in other words
both these values will be 8x8 but in
case we want to change to a higher
higher resolution texture we will have
to change that that's why I just created
this simple thing so we could have just
set this equal to like 1/8 but you know
obviously it's better to do it this way
in case we change the size later on so
we don't have to come in here and change
it and everything and the other thing I
want to do is actually get the RGB of it
and yeah that's okay before we do this
first of all let's just create our
actual result so our result is going to
equal new render and we will have the
width and height values as parameters
and we'll set this equal to 0 0 so it
starts in the top left corner actually
if we just hold our mouse at mouse over
here it should actually tell us what to
do or not
ok that's all right luckily I remember
it our width
our height our pixels because we want to
apply Kate what okay let me quickly
explain what get up get RGB does what
get RGB does is it gets the actual image
and it puts it into an array of integers
okay so we've set the width and height
of the image we've set where to start on
the image so zero by zero and now we
need to say okay where are you going to
put that array of integers that you've
created we need to put that array into
our pixels array all right
so we've made an object out of render
we've called it result let's now go
ahead and say apply this stuff to
results dot pixels right and zero and
with once again okay so hopefully this
cooperates I can actually show you yeah
okay nice awesome so you can see that
this is the start x value that's the
start y value that is the width and
height of our image that is our RGB
array that is the offset and that is the
scan size okay I'm not going to go into
details on this you can read up on this
if you guys aren't really comfortable
with using this stuff I would recommend
that you just go and read the Java
documentation okay I actually might put
a link to that down yeah I'll probably
put a link to a bunch of these api's
down in the description so if I don't
forget um if I forget just leave me a
comment I'll come come and do it but um
because this stuff's really important
and if you guys want to lose something
in Java for example if you want to add
to your game before I release the next
the next episode then it just go to go
to the Java documentation and check that
out because that stuff is really really
cool and if you want to create something
and you're not sure which method to use
for example but you know the API you
want to use and I honestly that's it's
pretty much the Java help file and it is
really really useful every Java
programmer uses that extensively ok and
now finally we actually want to return
that result value so
let's return it awesome and now we need
to catch our exception so basically we
want to say okay if it doesn't load the
image let's make the program crash so
let's throw a new runtime exception okay
cool
and we might print a nice thing saying
crash okay awesome
umm what's going on here unreachable
yeah okay let's put this before this in
okay cool umm so basically what we're
doing here with this whole thing let's
just sort this out a bit but no that's
fine
okay basically what we're doing with
this is we're saying let's go ahead and
try to load this image right if the
image so let's try and load this image
that is from filename which is right
here let's run let's try and load this
image if you cannot load the image for
any reason print crash and crash the
game so in other words if someone boots
up your game and for some reason they've
deleted a file by accident or they
didn't download the whole thing I don't
know something got corrupted and it
can't load the file let's not display
the graphically glitching version of our
game let's just not make the game
launched at all so this this stuff is
used in commercial games all the time
when they obviously the developer
doesn't want you to see the game in a
non text should not look like a really
glitchy State because then you'll judge
the game and then you'll you know it's
best it's not it's not ideal so what you
want to do is if half the files are
missing just don't launch the game make
it crash if you can't find that file and
if you can't load that file okay so
that's a really simple way of doing it
now before we actually launch this and
say it crash
we actually have to add our this we have
to actually have to add the resources
folder into our directory so if we just
refresh this we'll see the resources
folder but this isn't part of our build
path so what we need to do and
not carefully because the your game will
crash and it will say crash if this does
not work so you can see the resources
folder here and it's not really attached
to our thing at the moment it's just
chilling there we can open up this
original can see it but it's not
actually it's just in our directory it's
not actually attached to the game so
what we need to do is right-click on
mine front make sure you do this
otherwise it will crash please don't ask
me questions about why your game is
crashing if this is the problem because
listen up and do exactly what I do
right-click hit properties go to Java
build path go to libraries make sure
your it'll probably open like that go to
Java build path go to the libraries tab
hit add class folder check the resources
folder hit OK and hit OK now see this
little icon that appears next so that
means that it is referenced that means
that it is in your reference libraries
and it is part of the build path in
other words when you export your game
and when you debug it this will be
included ok you know you can also notice
here that I didn't go Res ok that's
because this is part of our folder so it
will just treat this as a folder you can
see that that doesn't have that little
thing next to it ok very important ok
now that's done we need to actually uh
you know use our image and actually
apply this particular image into our
floor into our rendering system so the
way we're going to do that is instead of
where are we here we are instead of
actually at the moment we're rendering
this and we're just rendering a bunch of
pixels and it makes a nice little image
instead of actually doing that we want
to set this equal to basically our floor
stuff so at the moment take one last
look where you've got this nice little
thing and now all we want to do is
replace it with this so let's come in
here and if you noticed we created its
static so if we go into texture
is static so that we can actually use it
in other classes without having to
initialize the opposition let's go ahead
and go to render 3d and type texture dot
floor because here is our static floor
method floor object texture floor dot
pixels because that is the array and we
use square brackets to indicate an array
and all we want to do here is go xbox
and seven plus same for y wipe x plus
seven and now we want to multiply that
by the size of our image in this case
eight and save that code well save that
code now if we launch it I get an array
index out of bounds exception which is
probably because I put should have put
and there let's launch it there we go
now you can see that we are using custom
textures the we just created in
paint.net okay simple stuff so yeah I'm
sure you guys will have a lot of fun
with this because you know it's fun to
create your own graphical content for
games and see it in action but the thing
that I sort of want to do quickly let's
come in here I'm just going to pick out
a nice brush and all I want to do here
is I'm going to draw like a little thing
basically to enter here to start and end
about grid okay let's save that okay
on second thoughts let's just have one
of these here that should be good enough
okay maybe not black though maybe you
want okay so yeah there we go and we can
if we can now clearly see the edge of
our blocks and they are completely
square as you can see okay so that is
that pretty much concludes our tutorial
today we're added the nice FPS counter
and we also added our custom textures
this guy this should last you awhile and
oh and we are going back to our normal
schedule of one episode every week on
Sunday so next week we've got a few
options next week oh and actually one
more thing before I move on to what's
next week um another thing that I wanted
to quickly show it was if you want like
an open sky then if we come up here
we've got this ceiling position thing
right and there's a position of our
ceiling now that we've added a render
distance limiter if we basically take it
out of the render distance it's not
going to render so if we move this up to
800 and save it we can see that we've
basically lost our ceiling it's
pitch-black now we can't see it and here
is basically just a nice floor plane
without any ceilings and I was actually
playing around this earlier and what you
can do is obviously save this to say
math adult sign game time so I'd buy ten
and Noble at about ten as well you can
get this animation gunner on going along
here and same with here so we had like
this this really like trippy sort of
thing now and let's set this like the
cosine of something so it's a bit
different so yeah that's little thing
and so actually lagging you'll see off
our FPS counter it's not lagging is just
basically we're dividing it by too much
let's put this down a full there we go
maybe three
yes that's little thing but basically
what I wanted to show you show you with
that was that if you want to get rid of
the sky get rid of the ceiling that's
how you do it
okay um so next week um I don't know
what we'll do next week we have the
choice of completing our mouse movement
we have the choice of adding jumping and
that's it I can't forgive anything
anything else live right now so next
week's tutorial
episode 16 will either be jumping or
advanced mouse movements so head over to
the famous channel page and vote and not
well not really vote but yeah vote for
other people's responses but also type
in your own response as to what you want
next episode and I will see you guys
later
but one more exam tomorrow Roach
commander is coming from on warfare 3
I'm pumped and I cannot wait I actually
haven't opened it yet so I haven't even
played it yet if you saw my last update
video you know what I mean and and yeah
so basically next week starting next
week or actually probably this week
depends when you watch this video but
starting next week you'll probably be
seeing a video every day for me ok one
once a week Java video but every day I
will be having a Rocha commander video
come out so that should be awesome
make sure to watch that it'll be a lot
of fun and I'll be live-streaming a lot
as well so if you guys want to ask me
any questions live then you'll be able
to do that ok guys I will see you later
and I hope you enjoyed this tutorial
goodbye